i was actually watching the show back
last night
and sometimes i study it to see what i
can fix and improve and um believe me i
don't sit around watching myself all the
time
but i noticed that marie kondo's picture
was facing this way and i felt like
no no no no marie needs to face
out so i'm so sorry marie
i had you in the wrong position and that
won't happen again
hashtag closer to condo okay so we're
gonna jump into
all the pop headlines right away that
you need to know about
it's pop culture and entertainment
tonight edition
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't help it i'm i'm working the
lasso
okay joining me is my co-pilot and a
true expert because he's the host of
entertainment tonight
and my friend the lovely kevin frazier
drew what's going on how are you sworn
how are you doing today i'm good kevin
how are you i'm so good you know marie
condo actually came
and cleaned up my office so the fact
that you have her
picture there is amazing
did you meet her in person um
i went out of town and they brought her
into my office nichelle who's next door
and she reorganized my office while i
was gone
it was crazy okay i'm sorry i have to
pull it together
okay we'll we'll sidebar about that
afterwards i can shake it off shake it
off shake it off okay hashtag closer to
condor
condo okay um okay first up this
story is so important the la lakers they
won their first championship in 10 years
and lebron
got its fourth ring and we have
officially seen the end
of the nba bubble how is la celebrating
this huge
important meaningful win in this
ever most important meaningful year
listen there's no parade um that will
come
later on after the bubble is over but
there was a party inside the bubble
down in orlando the guys had a great
time some people here in la celebrated
but
you know as i know that this town
belongs to kobe bryant
and it's all about kobe bryant and this
win was for kobe
his widow vanessa wrote a beautiful and
touching message
to everyone out there in laker nation
and
you have to remember rob polinka who is
the general manager of the team was
kobe's best friend
but he was also kobe's daughter gianna's
godfather so he
he you know this has been a special
mission for him and so to see the lakers
win you know you can't go
five feet in l.a without seeing another
kobe and gianna mural so i am so happy
our hearts are with vanessa and it's
it's a magic moment for la
it really is it's special so glad and i
realized that it
uh his passing happened in 2020 it was
and and that was something i hadn't
really realized and calculated that it
was all within this calendar year
and this extraordinary year and i'm so
glad
that something positive and healing and
honoring
and spiritually uplifting and my friend
christy who i do social media with we
always talk she always says
when there's sports there's hope and to
see that the bubble worked
to see that la is getting to celebrate
in all the ways that
it should it's
we need to hold on to these moments when
something goes in a direction
eventually uplifting eventually drew
will get to celebrate
eventually there will be one heck of a
party as you know okay well
well deserved well deserved and lebron
he's just
he's he just he comes through every time
so
um on a much lighter note um we just got
a brand new croc creation
the justin bieber limited edition
oh and they drop today the biebs
designed him himself
kevin you're gonna rock a croc i would
rock a croc
um you know his um new collaboration
with crocs has a shout out to his
clothing brand drew house
they have a little few little pins and
stuff on the front they're yellow
they're cool listen i like the justin
bieber croc and there was the bad bunny
croc which sold out in minutes i think
the bieber croc will go fast but if i'm
gonna rock a croc
you know there's only one brand of crock
i'm gonna rock drew
come on it's the drew barrymore croc
well thank you
for mentioning it kevin yes i did i i
kicked off a big
sort of like turning point in uh crocs
they just they wanted to
i think their whole direction they went
with post malone i was honored that they
asked me
to come and join the club i loved being
an
ambassador for them and justin bieber's
company is called drew because that's
his middle name
so you i've actually provided him with
images
like he has drew t-shirts with my face
on it which is so fun
and we just have a lot of symmetry and
that's really exciting
okay um the scream i love that i love
that and i want to say that you know
what
follow your passion that's an important
thing when celebs follow their passion
and do something that they love and so
you could tell you love the crocs okay
go ahead go scream i do i do and i love
justin bieber so
you know um okay but something else that
i love and i feel very loyal too
is scream five and what's the scoop
kevin
it's shooting now it is shooting out and
all the og's are back and i really do
think drew that this gives you the
opportunity to break a little news right
now because anything's possible in the
movies anything is possible
could you be back for screen five since
all the ogs are coming back would you do
it
could they find a way to bring you back
even though you're like did you see what
happened to me in that movie
yeah i did i'm gonna need a lot of ace
bandages to come back
okay but one of the folks who's back is
nev campbell she is fantastic in this
franchise and guess what drew
nev has a special shout out for you we
caught up with her last night
listen up yes drew it's nev
oh my goodness i'm about to go shoot
scream
five in two weeks
and i hearken back to our beginning the
first film what that's done for my
career having you in that film and what
that did for that film
you're so amazing you always have been i
hope all is well
thank you nev and thank you kevin i have
to say having drew's news
with entertainment tonight like that's
another
good collab that really means so much to
me and my heart you're the best
please come back and do this with me
again okay god please please
news kevin you're the best